man versus food coming soon to Travel
Channel four and a half pound Irish
Breakfast in Boston to a three and a
half pound sandwich in Burlington
Vermont the new host Casey Webb steps up
to the challenge with gusto new man new
food same epic battle
Casey joins us here as they get ready
for new season a man V food what'd you
have for breakfast
nothing coffee what did you have for
dinner last night dinner was this is
just great place down where I grew up in
Jersey it's tide tacos so it's an
authentic little Mexican place that has
some great tacos but what do people
expect when they see you out eat a lot
more food than I probably do on you know
on the regular basis or something really
spicy so it's yeah they expect a lot but
are you competitive do you have to be
competitive with what you're doing for
the purposes of the show oh yeah
it's I mean I train like any other
athlete would you know put my gym
clothes on fall asleep on the couch and
then wear the gym clothes all day and
then you know that's pretty much like
working out but no I mean it's very much
like you have to prepare yourself for
these larger things spicy things okay
but how does one become the host of man
vs. food that's a good question I think
you know the show was on for four
seasons and then it was off for five
years
and then the good folks that travel
channel wanted to bring it back so they
scoured the countryside and wannabe and
me so it was more of an audition process
well how do you audition so basically it
was the show in a limited amount of time
and then there was a challenge at the
end of it to see if one could take down
you know it was like a burger challenge
so pretty good
you had other guys that you're competing
with for the two you know it was a
one-on-one thing it was me and food it
wasn't anything different than what the
show is now but they kept it under wraps
we didn't know that it was gonna be mvf
so it was a surprise to me when I
finally was told that I got the show I
was like oh okay I guess I'm gonna be
busy how often does food win um you know
you have to tune in Dan in the second
season you know it's it's I
definitely underdog in this I'm not a
professional competitive food eater but
I now I am you know I'm now the face of
that so it's been a challenge to say the
least but it's been exceptionally that's
been fun
you know it's been a lot of fun to take
on these these challenges as a kid you
know there was like there's a pizza
challenge down on the Jersey Shore that
it took on there's a milk challenge and
that was fun
and then I'm you know being in the
restaurant business as long as I have
been it's just these two worlds collided
you know from you know I have some
acting background as well so but the
milk challenge is that to drink a gallon
they drink a gallon of milk I don't
suggest it guys know if you've ever done
that
you guys are dairy-free huh yeah bunch
of vegans all right studio audience do
you think somebody could drink a gallon
of milk you can't that's the thing no
some people probably with longer bellies
probably take it take it take it down
but your body just gives up on it when's
the last time you sat down and you're
looking at that meal you're looking at
food and you just know that foods
looking back and laughing at you every
time every time yeah have you ever had
an advantage where you felt like I got
this well it's definitely you have to
psych yourself up you have to get into
that so-called zone when taking on any
sort of challenge in life right so food
is no different yeah laughs see in the
face and then you you know you do your
best to conquer it and sometimes you win
sometimes you lose when you get fully
you stop eating what's the single most
daunting meal you ever have it would
have to be spicy the spicy stuff is
because when you're done eating it's
it's not done it's just starting just
starting so that's you know that that's
probably the most daunting out of all of
them spicy ones yeah are you gonna be in
Minnesota with us at the Super Bowl yeah
is that an invitation
sure I would love to be there because
Paulie has a place or at least there's a
kind of hamburger that you love there
yeah very popular Minnesota's Juicy Lucy
burgers there's a few different places
and they put two burgers cheese inside
and they're fantastic but there's a lot
of debates over which had the best one
we want to try all of them there's two
main ones if you need you need a pro in
your corner guys be more than happy tag
along he walks in and greases the wheels
yeah right
literally but do people who try to
challenge you when you're not on camera
with food not yet it hasn't happened yet
thankfully because I if I saw you
walking in right and I love a piece of
you it's on then I would say I'm gonna
order for you
oh and then let's go I mean if people
start buying me meals sure you know my
relationship might be suffer from that
you know my girlfriend might hate me but
you know do you watch your food I mean
how much you i watch it do you know the
intake of it watch your weight your
health all of these things cuz you're
not eating healthy here right I mean
these are foods that we craved and like
these are foods that you crave that I
crave that these guys definitely crave
so you know you have to watch your
intake I gotta take care of myself like
anybody else all kidding aside I do get
off the couch after putting my gym
clothes on and go to the gym you do it's
important you know for the purpose of
the show you know that is I'm eating
those foods you know there's no question
of that
outside of that I don't eat it that way
every day you know but for the show it's
it's a show about you know this greater
competition so people have to be so
disappointed if you go to a restaurant
there's no cameras there and all of a
sudden they see you having like a little
salad or something it's like yeah I'm
eating a little bit lighter in
preparation to take on this giant thing
so like wait so yeah there's a little
bit of that but you know I still gotta
take care of myself no pics where you go
so we have a great folk set with the
production company they have a team of
people that that look for places
throughout the country so as a result of
the show being on the air for four
seasons it's been five years off season
right so there's thousands of new places
that have opened up that have challenges
so a lot of times folks call in or
they'll write in fans or people that
love those restaurants will you know
send an email over to the production
company but okay you should check us out
if you have time if you're coming
through whatever city USA so yeah it's
been it's been great there's no shortage
of places to go to as I found out
coolest place you've been to you know
I'm so in love with New Orleans I was
able to able to go there last season so
that's last season first season was New
Orleans there's such a beautiful city
and so much history and then this season
we got to go to Pittsburgh which I had
never been to I'm from New York New
Jersey area
it's not Chicago it's not Philly it's
not New York it's its own little island
Pittsburgh and it's it's that is such a
blast people are so great huge food
scene huge beer scene so yeah it's
probably one my new favorite place but
you have people who were there watching
you eat oh yeah
does that help or hurt honestly it's
that's what gets me through it that's
what gets me to the other side cuz when
you know this your backs against against
the wall with some of this stuff it's
it's hard to push through and when
someone's cheering you on like any sport
you know coming from a sports background
it really pushes me over and it's it's
it's changed the game for me you know
it's it was a difference between win or
lose sometimes you know where here's
somebody you're not like a little kid
shooting on and I start laughing then I
just push through you know when's the
last time you throw up I think I was in
college also never never on the show
after the show you know I know actually
I when you full stop eating you know
when you're done stop eating guys that's
just my advice to everybody out there
[Laughter]
you guys have a big meal I heard
recently we did dice tonight we had
steak yeah very good it's still going
well still going what's that on that one
but you look like you may have played
some football there I did yeah I was
lucky enough to play high school and a
little bit of college football it played
some baseball as a kid I looked more
like Babe Ruth and played like dr. Ruth
but football player I was a better
football player you've got some Chris
Farley mannerisms - yeah face a lot of
face some body turn turns yeah lucky
enough I have my you know I got a you
know I I have the same expression on my
face as I as I did when I was a little
kid so that's that's been fridge she
does a pretty good Chris Farley
impersonation there he's Casey Webb male
host of Travel Channel's man vs. food
premieres Monday December 4th at 90
great to see you thanks for joining us
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]